[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of episode seven of season two of
euphoria it is the pen ultimate episode
once again this is directed and written
by sam levinson
so
we finally get lexi's play here and it's
an interesting choice for it to be in
the penultimate episode and i had a lot
of mixed feelings about this episode
it's interesting because they also go
with the choice of a time jump here from
all the events of season two
but i don't know how much it was worth
it to make lexi's play the focus point
in a penultimate episode where you're
really expecting more stuff to develop
and it sort of in a way takes away from
some of the main plots we've been
following along here especially with
ruse and it also makes it feel weird
when we're seeing roof scenes in this
episode that don't really
feel natural and flow to this episode
and that
maybe it would have been better if this
was a full episode of lexi's play but
earlier in the season or why isn't the
season just longer if you're gonna do
something like this like maybe a couple
more episodes instead of eight that the
finale is next week you know it's it's
strange but i'm gonna break down this
whole episode and what i liked what i
didn't like and with lexi's play we get
this over long overture here in the
beginning that i thought my screen froze
for a second i thought i'd have to share
that see if anyone related to that felt
like an idiot you're an idiot what i did
like a lot
about this episode the technicality of
it was so impressive and
the visuals were awesome i loved seeing
these stage versions of our characters
we know and then it cutting back and
forth between the real life versions and
the stage versions and that we got
really our first glimpse of lexi's
friends as the stage versions at rue's
dad's memorial so i thought that was
pretty cool and they did a good job of
blending it and that's just with the
sets too how great they replicated the
real life
areas and environments and then it would
transfer to the set on stage really cool
and it was unique i like that and it's
just a good idea on paper right it's a
cool
experience that we're seeing our
characters see mirror versions of
themself on the stage they're facing
themselves and it's also lexi showing
her perspective on everybody in this
show and we're seeing that through the
play it's the beauty of art now what
might surprise people is
lexi is one of the most likable
characters on this show probably a fan
favorite and she tells fez in this
episode her intentions are good with the
play and that you know we see though she
didn't really give a heads up to anybody
that the play
is the characters based off them in real
life so it's a shocker to our characters
when they see this but what is a head
scratcher is that lexi says to feather
intentions are good right
what she didn't mention was her
intentions were not good towards nate
and how that would affect her sister
also because
what this episode does is as the show
has constantly made you hate nate
there's moments that sam clearly wants
you to feel sympathy for even the most
despicable character of nate that comes
clearly in our big moment at the end
here but what that also does is it
actually surprisingly makes you like
lexi a lot less and lexi is now really
great in this episode and that comes
from her tyrant behavior uh how she
talks to certain people she is the
director of there's moments where it's
you know it's understandable as a
director and you're you know you're
moving along getting everyone in their
places but then there's moments how
she's just brutal to the like guy in the
name she calls him but her darkest part
is
her being okay with making a completely
homophobic act at the end of this play
and as much as we don't like nate nate
is completely right when he is leaving
storming off saying that it was
homophobic yeah he actually is right
about that but what always frustrates me
about scenes like this because
sam levinson is clearly writing this to
kind of fool you right because you're
seeing lexi hasn't really crossed the
line yet yes she's making your sister
the dummy of the play the laugh of the
play but
i do believe she had good intentions
with that storyline and that cassie was
actually coming around to it towards the
end that it wasn't so bad blooded let's
say but the stuff with nate is bizarre
because you see the stage manager he
writes says this is brilliant and
everyone's clapping and cheering for
lexi and sam's clearly going to show
that
that
isn't brilliant that was the wrong
approach because it was really poor
taste but what annoys me is that doing
that story and that moment really makes
me scratch my head because
everyone we know from the show like rue
jewels they're all standing up and going
bravo to this completely homophobic
moment which i thought was like what
like do you want me to not like any of
these characters and i get they all hate
nate right and that
that's where a lot of their joy of
seeing that's coming from but in that
way of showing that and that they're all
agreeing with that not one of them is
sitting there like oh this is still bad
i don't know what the hell is going on
there so i did not like that and i don't
really believe they'll have a
explanation for that from every one of
those people it's just gonna be you know
looked over which annoys me and i think
that's a huge mistake i think that that
needs to be addressed and that each
character even in a scene where it's not
their focus is still reacting in their
head as their character and that they're
all down with homophobia it's like okay
uh
all right so i don't know very strange
because they're gonna be able to address
it with lexi clearly and i don't know
i didn't like it just because of the
characters we had involved with it that
i just don't see how they're gonna
address that with every one of them but
we'll get more back to how it ends with
cassie with that but
what i did think worked in this episode
was
what lined up well was the tension built
here with fez right and that custer and
fair at the house and custer's clearly
got his phone ready to listen in for the
cops ashtrays on to them faye wants to
say something there's good tension built
there and it works well blending with
the play because we know lexi's waiting
for fez and that she got him the seat
we've also learned they've been talking
for months so it's building up this
heartbreak for lexi and that clearly fez
is in
deep [ __ ] for next episode so we'll see
what happens with that i also loved
ethan playing all these characters
especially loved him playing susie i
thought that was so funny the way he
just said the line okay ladies i'm not
running a brothel here it's time for bed
i thought was just incredible i could
watch a whole episode of him playing
susie but going back to what's talking
about my complaint with now
forcing in these ru scenes with her
sister that's important her talking
about their memories of their dad
possibly fading as they get older and
then this scene that's also important
with his roo's mom saying that she broke
her you're gonna kill yourself doing
drugs i'm not getting in your way and
she's gonna be 18 soon gonna be out of
the house i'm taking off my plate and
really protecting gia and she says this
harsh thing which is like if i have to
choose between losing one daughter two
i'm gonna fight to save her so what's
confusing about this is it seems like
rue is sober in this timeline we're not
totally sure about that
but
the way she's behaving and even the way
she's watching the play seems like that
so i'm trying to figure out why her mom
was talking to her at this moment this
way it makes sense maybe if she was
still doing heavy drugs so there's
something we got to learn there but
again we just had so much time to rule
story the past two episodes and
there's a lot of stuff built up there
and this what happened so i would have
liked to still see more of that so
that's why i felt odd that the lexi play
was now because we got one episode left
to wrap up a lot of stuff here and
there's little moments you gotta catch
you're like this really effective moment
of the play i thought was
maddie and cassie when they were showing
them bonding in this bed and cassie
comforting her was great it was great to
watch maddie and cassie react out you
see cassie leaves and when cassie leaves
upset about it because it hits too close
to home you know lexi's there and
notices during the play she sees cassie
leave the auditorium but it leads to
sydney sweeney having probably her best
acting in the show yet and it's so
similar definitely inspired by the high
tonya scene with another amazing actress
in margot robbie where she's looking
into the mirror she's trying to keep a
smile on and keep that mask on they
always have but they're dying inside and
that cindy sweeney just kills it and
it's just one titan being inspired by
another one in margot ravi
but that's where those flashbacks work
with when
maddie was running up to yell at cassie
in her room and again it's because it's
lining up well with the play and what is
showing you through the play stuff in
their past that worked but again like
this ruined jewel stuff it just
again these moments are important with
roof talking about jewels and how they
haven't been talking and ruth's still
referring to it as a [ __ ]
intervention so maybe she is still doing
drugs who knows but again that just is
so foreign to the play it's it's
not lining up with what we're seeing in
the play oh and also we see cats back
doing webcams uh this story is just a
mess like it's just a drop story at this
point i i don't know what is going on
with cat we're not getting any info here
it's a giant circle like
she was doing webcams last season then
isn't now
treats ethan like crap and then they
break up and now she's doing webcams
again okay i haven't learned anything
about cat but you see through the play
the main difference of cassie and lexi
how lexi views cassie and that you know
lexi's all about self-respect as a woman
you know using the brain
doing things that are looking out for
yourself and being smart and then like
cassie's just everything about
non-independence and that you know she's
writing her as someone who her whole
life
is to be loved by somebody else and be
there for somebody else it's dependency
and it's totally different viewpoint in
life but that was well written i thought
and i do really love that he also did
some
david lynch horror vibes here because
like one of my favorite things about
david lynch is his way he does horror
and i was clearly inspired by that with
nate looking in the mirror here and he's
turning around and he's looking at
maddie but maddie becomes jewels and
comes over to nate and we just get
another glimpse of the storyline that
could have been that would have been way
better if it was jules and nate instead
of
nate and cassie but i love love the
score here when nate's having this dream
and it's of his dad
going to basically do some intense
violent sexual stuff with him and it's
also explained to us why nate gets that
from his father and what he viewed on
the tapes of his father and he's doing
that with cassie it's learned behavior
now we see jules destroys the dvd of
that footage it's all we really get
mostly of jewels here not much has been
happening in the jewels world and the
story at the moment and maddie's talking
about how she's got to tell samantha's
kid that she's you know leaving the area
leaving east highland moving on to
graduate right and
what's important about this though
samantha giving her a gift and it's that
dress
that she really likes that samantha had
but it's also to me telling that it's
visually telling you what i've been
predicting as i said this story with
maddie that maddie might show cassie
some forgiveness clearly seeing that
scene in the play where they were
bonding and also the talk samantha had
with her now her putting on that dress
maybe kind of connects her to samantha
but also connects her to cassie what
samantha was saying about
maybe giving cassie a chance but let's
go back now to this last moment right in
the reaction to it with cassie and nate
and nate of course nate somehow puts
blame on cassie too for it happening
that last scene put your pack your stuff
he says and get out of my house which is
gonna clearly piss off cassie because
that's cassie's world and that
relationship with nate and
now she's gonna be furious at lexi and
we get that psycho cassie that was
hinted at i talked about that we were
gonna see that was hinted at a couple
episodes ago when she was talking to
nate and saying she could go that level
like maddie does of psycho and we see
that monster version of cassie through
the auditorium door
wow what a shot and it was haunting
cindy sweeney's face and for her to be
able to go there was awesome she really
wants that emmy this season i think she
needs to get recognized at least
nominated and i'd be happy for her
winning two so it's been long overdue
for that actress of sydney sweeney so
this episode was just incredible by her
on all fronts and they leave it with it
to be continued
but it still feels odd the whole episode
feels strange like i don't feel that
satisfied i think i would have liked
this episode way more again in the
middle of the season why doesn't the
season have more episodes i don't know
it's bizarre but
it is frustrating i think as a viewer
because you're watching it wanting more
from the main stories and we get this
time jump that we don't really get many
answers on what happened during that
time jump and we're seeing a lot of
stuff we kind of already knew through
lexi's play we get a lot of new
information too but
it's just kind of setting up that lexi's
not as good as we thought maybe and that
she's got some serious character flaws
as well but i don't know how i feel
about like okay well lexi's just
blatantly homophobic and that
everyone we know in the show is
homophobic i guess i don't know i'm just
baffled a bit so we'll see how they
address it but i'm giving an 8.1 hate me
all you want for what i'm saying about
that stuff but i just hate because i've
seen it happen in so many shows where
they're trying to set up two things with
two characters that lexi has this gray
side of her and that we're giving nate
some sympathy here and that's going to
be the downfall of this play but it's
ignoring how important it is how
everyone we know is reacting to this
play why are they all just standing up
and going
you know nuts over this scene so
i don't know i thought some would have a
little more of a conscience here but i'm
giving an 8.1 it's got great visuals but
it's still a little slow you expect more
for pen ultimate episode and i just felt
like the roux scenes were just so forced
in with the play and didn't flow and i
feel like that's a problem a lot of this
season is the pacing and things not
really kind of coming tight and flowing
together and
it's disappointing because i think we
had such a good two episodes there in
the middle especially with the rue on
their own episode the intervention where
i thought last week was eh and this
one's good it's good you know and more
towards the visual side of things and
the music but
i don't know you know again acting too
but story-wise
you know again it still is in that giant
circle feeling and we're just kind of
now set up out of nowhere this cassie
lexi showdown and there's just pieces of
this story in the season i don't feel
like getting enough attention don't get
me started about cat but we'll see what
happens in the finale
i hope it's good you know but for
euphoria standards the last two weeks
have been a bit of a letdown so we'll
see i hope it's good the finale uh but
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
one of my reviews of euphoria and please
comment let me know your thoughts on
this episode theories for next week i
want to hear what you liked what you
didn't like what you agree with me
disagree with me on i appreciate all the
comments i read all of them and try to
respond as many as i can please follow
me at steve barley show on twitter
instagram and tick tock for more of me
and i'll see you next time